C I want to talk to you about Prince
Harry it's not a subject I ever
willingly bring up uh from a sense of
personal Joy about wanting to discuss
him uh however he keeps putting himself
back in the news and he's in court again
in London today demanding to have Royal
protection whenever he and his family
are in the UK despite quitting the
country quitting Royal Duty and spending
the last few years trashing the family
and the monarchy should he be entitled
to have Royal prote
well actually uh even in the core case
that is now happening one of the things
that is clear is that he was being
offered protection as any high-profile
public figure would be in the UK it was
simply not at the level of that a
working Royal would be offered uh and
appears you say you don't bring this up
willingly I don't really pay much
attention to these people but I do
remember distinctly some time ago them
quitting public life and moving on and
since then all we have seen is them
complaining in about one thing after
another first there was the fake racism
about the baby now it's this and it just
never seems to stop and it seems to me
that they quite enjoy their attention I
know that's a cynical interpretation but
it just seems to me that they can't live
without the attention and they're
quoting it
deliberately yeah and AA you know I
talked with Neil Ferguson about this
secondary issue of the way that they
tainted with that Oprah interview the
entire country via the prism of our
figureheads the Royal Family and the
monarchy as a bunch of callous racists
when in fact you know this is from a
historian like Neil who knows better
than most uh what a racist intolerant
place looks like and he you know by any
normal metric Britain is one of the most
tolerant places in the world I think
that you I mean I think you know what
you're saying there you know you've made
a decision that the royal family haven't
done anything racist and there's not
going to be any further scrutiny of
whether you know anyone in the royal
family said something to upset Megan but
look you know we were all there for the
last couple of years and the couple of
years leading up to their well sorry not
a couple of years but the couple of
months leading up to their wedding we do
know how the Press treated mean Markle
and we do know that there were a lot of
allegations made against her that I'm
sorry they could be called racist you
know she she had a very terrible time
look I'm not going to go over all the
accusations I mean there was well name
one okay so her skin color was you know
she was called exotic that was a pretty
racist thing to say and you know yeah
that was Rachel Rachel Johnson joh the
reason
Rachel has yes has you know corrected
that in you know the years followed that
but you know there were many there were
accusations leveled at her that were
completely unfair I mean there was a
two-page spread given to her consumption
avoc it to it was totally
ridiculous but they weren't racist and
my point is if if you go back and look
at the Press coverage on the wedding day
for example I know I wrote The Man on
Sunday's big piece on it um everyone was
welcoming in this country the idea of a
biracial marriage into to the royal
family a tinge racism Yes actually
pretty much
everybody fans of the Premier League
aren't racist and we do know that people
who comment on you know all the
footballers Instagrams after every
single match do put racist comments on
there but you can make an argument that
the Premier League itself is not racist
look I think there was a level of
introspection that was leveled at Megan
marle that was totally unfair totally
uncalled for and no wonder she basically
had a breakdown had to leave the
country yeah I don't think it was that
at all I think she was a very cic
person who decided to hook her Clause
into Prince Harry as a meal ticket for
Life dragged him back to California for
the good life in the Mansion where they
trade off their Royal titles for
hundreds of millions of dollars and I
think it's despicable however we can
agree to disagree maybe on this one we
might find some agreement uh Constantine
this uh once again this issue of trans
athletes competing in women's sport has
read a very ugly head in terms of what
happened in Illinois in a cycling
competition a women's cycling race where
the gold and silver medals were won by
two biological males identifying as
trans women now this is the latest in a
long series of these faral results in
women's sport which are clearly eroding
the fairness and equality and integrity
of women's sport and my question is
simply why are we still allowing this to
happen why why a are official Sports
bodies not just Banning it completely
when there such an obvious disadvantage
to women born with Fe female biological
bodies but secondly um why aren't more
women standing up is it because the ones
who do get get crucified at the altar of
trans activism well I hear AA touting
next to me so I'm fearful of what I'm
about to say but look first of all on
the trans women in in in women's sports
thing I we are all looking for the next
I don't know what to say I mean it is so
obvious we have had Richard Dawkins on
trigonometry Sharon Davis the former
British Olympics swimmer detailing bit
by bit by bit every way in which men
have a physical advantage over women
when it comes to physical competition
and by the way you don't need to be a
scientist you just need to have a brain
look around to know that there is a
physical difference between men and
women uh as for why more women don't
stand up look first of all I think we
should acknowledge there are many many
very courageous women who have uh spoken
out about this and I just mentioned
Sharon Davis but I could give you a list
as long as my arm but I do actually
agree with you jking yes of course I I
generally don't uh buy into sort of
allegations the men and women are
treated differently in lots of different
fields but I do think actually on this
issue uh it is true women I think are
perceived as being slightly more
vulnerable and the Very hateful bigoted
trans activists that go after people
especially online uh they do seem to
Target the women more so I think it's
actually on the men in and the women in
this case but particularly on the men to
stand up and lead in saying this is is
completely ridiculous and it needs to
end okay AA my question for you when was
the last time a trans man competed
against biological men and beat them I
just don't think that we would have that
level of introspection it's probably
that journalists aren't trying to hunt
out that story because they don't think
it's going to make headline news look at
the moment no no no no no no no no no aa
aa it hasn't happened that's why no
one's written about it look at the
moment no one writes about trans men
winning against men because they don't
beat them P at the moment we are
currently you know we're currently
witnessing the trial of banay who was
you know a young trans girl who you know
sadly lost her life and you know we'll
have to see what comes out of the court
I can't say too much more on it but also
you know a colleague of mine just
returned from a a young trans boy who'
taken his own life the way that we are
treating trans people in this country is
disgusting there is such a small
proportion of them and I don't
understand there why we won't leave them
alone yeah but one of the reason reasons
why trans people are getting a hard time
is because of this ridiculous defense of
the indefensible over the issue of trans
athletes in women's sport it makes an
absolute mockery of all trans people I
know trans people who wish us would all
just go away that trans people would
stop trying to fight at this ridiculous
alar of unfairness and battle for their
own fairness and equality they are they
what they're fighting for is just to be
recognized and just to be left alone you
know I it doesn't need to be this
headline media speculation Insanity all
the time if perhaps the media showed
some care for them every other day of
the year then maybe we could have a
sensible conversation about sport maybe
I could you know start talking to you
normally about perhaps what is going on
you know with the cycling but frankly I
don't really care when I know that trans
people are taking their own lives every
single day what about the women who are
competing in these Sports and who are
not getting an opportunity to compete
fit fairly Sur guys Constantine I've
loved having you back please come back
again soon AA always good to have you to
disagree thank you very much inde for
watching